au compte- ntoh secrétaire départemental
de l'unité sgp police de paris est avec
nous sur ce plateau rocco contento
bonsoir anne soir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
on vient de voir les attentes des
électeurs se porte surtout sur la
sécurité routière la sécurité à l'école
et la gestion des agressions est-ce qu
augmenter les pouvoirs du maire en
matière de sécurité
aujourd'hui c'est la solution alors déjà
il faut faire une différence entre paris
et le reste de la france ce sont deux
domaines particuliers je précise qu' il
est vrai que les agents municipaux
on est dans une période terroriste
actuelle
je me souviens lors des attentats de
janvier 2015
un pauvre collègues agente municipale
qui a été tué donc c'est vrai que la
police nationale malheureusement ne peut
pas tout faire nous sur les polices
municipales à l'unité sgp police nous
avons le disons que nous ne sommes pas
réfractaire sauf à paris mais faut que
les choses soient bien bornes et c'est
important
sakho fait le périmètre de leur mission
qui n'empiète pas sur les missions de la
police nationale la formation de ses
agents la qui est aussi importante il
faut vraiment bien les former et pour
que la population passe pas d'amalgamé
entre police nationale et police
municipale avec deux détenus bien
différentes mais par exemple dans une
ville moyenne
la police municipale on l'a vu dans le
sondage les électeurs est vrai que par
exemple le maire chef de la police
municipale puisse avoir accès par
exemple au fichier s ou alors aux
personnes potentiellement dangereuses
est ce que ça pourrait être une solution
selon vous pour lutter contre
l'insécurité
alors ça peut être des solutions
simplement que en général on ouvre on
l'a vu d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de
reportages
il ya souvent en province dans les
villes de province une très bonne
coordination entre la police nationale
et la police municipale avec un partage
des informations
alors que le maire est directement accès
aux fichiers ou que ce soit le
commissaire de la ville
voilà l'essentiel c'est que ça va passer
de ces informations par don soit partagé
moi ça ne me choque pas que le maire
soit détenteur de ces informations là à
après on verra comment les choses se
passent dans dans les villes et je fais
vraiment une exception vraiment pour
paris c'est à dire pour paris nous a
noté jp police nous étions complètement
réfractaires
des deux polices municipales
malheureusement elle va voir le jour
bientôt il ya un enjeu électoral
important en bachmann hidalgo qui vous
avez reçu il ya cinq ans vous avez dit
qu'elle était réfractaire à toute idée
de police municipale alors aujourd'hui
elles veulent a créé d'ailleurs
anormalité empêché par le pouvoir
puisque sa principale qui doit voir le
jour en février ne verra pas le jour et
on voit aussi les autres candidats
monsieur griveaux qui aussi veut
annoncer la création d'une police
municipale a pris avec 5000 agents
donc voilà en tout cas comment est ce
qu'on peut comprendre ce sondage c'est à
dire qu'on voit les français qui veulent
plus de sécurité plus de pouvoir de leur
mère de leur police municipale ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui que la police
nationale ou la gendarmerie n'ont plus
les moyens non plus les capacités pour
intervenir dans les tons et en plus
c'est un exemple alors je fais la
différence
toujours pareil entre les autres de
province et puis surtout paris et le
ressort de la petite couronne et la
grande couronne
il faut savoir par exemple qu'à paris
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir sabo qui t'a
pas échappé que depuis plus d'un an et
demi nous sommes mobilisés sur les
manifestations
gilet jaune et ensuite les grosses
manifestations qu'on a vu contre la
réforme des retraites qui mobilise
toutes les ressources policières pas que
les effectifs 21 l'ordre aussi l'écho
les collègues des commissariats qui sont
aussi mis à contribution tout le temps
ce qui fait que malheureusement le
pendant de tout ça c'est que nous ne
pourrons pas là puisque nationale ne
peut pas répondre à tous les appels
un exemple on a beaucoup de nuisances à
paris de tapage nocturne au vu vous
n'intervenez plus réellement fait genre
de notation interviennent au terme et
non pas mais que nous n'avons pas assez
d'effectifs et de véhicules pour
intervenir un exemple le 19ème
arrondissement de paris peu près 150
mille habitants la nuit
vous avez deux quatre ou deux véhicules
de police pour l'arrondissement est
effectivement et sont mis à contribution
souvent sur des délits des affaires
importantes et c'est vrai que lorsque le
recevons des appels pour des huit sens
des nuances part donc pour des tapages
on priorise l'émission est évidemment on
peut pas répondre à ce genre de demande
c'est pour ça qu'une police municipale
pour est entre guillemets le s'occupe
étude de ce genre de choses
allez constater les infractions et faire
des vins verbalisation mais il faut que
les choses soient bien bordé un policier
municipal n'est pas un agent de police
judiciaire à l'article 20 il faut bien
faire la différence
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe les
policiers municipaux lorsque en province
il constate des délits il interpellé
personne et ensuite font appel à la
police nationale pour ensuite en est la
personne se faire au dossier auditionné
chez un officier de police judiciaire
après il faut des protocoles entre la
police nationale et la police municipale
voilà pour conclure cette question est
ce que au fond il faut aussi repenser la
collaboration entre police nationale
police municipale et gendarmerie lala la
coopération entre police nationale
police municipale se passe vraiment
d'une manière très correcte
en province on le voit même dans les
grandes villes de province un bon les
chefs sont fait elle est à paris mais
effectivement il ya encore des progrès à
faire dans ce dans ce domaine là merci
beaucoup aux enfants contents d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire départemental cgt
police de paris